as night fell her swat team moved in
after nearly 11 hours of negotiations
involving multiple intelligence agencies
and a family from lancashire agents from
the fbi brought the siege at the texas
synagogue to an end
two hostages emerged from a fire exit
followed by a third
there had been four of them held hostage
inside the building including the rabbi
one had been released earlier this was
the moment the others were freed
the authorities had been called to the
congregation beth israel synagogue hours
earlier to reports of a hostage-taking
we began to get information that a
gunman had entered the synagogue and
taken
four individuals hostage he did release
one hostage in the middle of the
incident that hostage was not harmed and
he was uh he was he's doing well now
listeners to the synagogue service live
stream already knew something was wrong
a man with a british accent was heard
interrupting the service
[Music]
until the live stream was cut he could
be heard shouting in english at the
hostages and in punjabi to relatives on
the phone i'm pumped up i'm armed up he
said
investigators working with their uk
counterparts had quickly identified him
as malik vessel akram 44 from lancashire
and his family were quickly part of the
negotiations they've now released a
statement it is with great great sadness
i will confirm my brother fassel passed
away in texas usa this morning we are
absolutely devastated as a family we
would like to say that we as a family do
not condone any of his actions and would
like to sincerely apologize
wholeheartedly to all the victims
involved in the unfortunate incident
sky news has been told that he traveled
to the united states two weeks ago on
january the second how did he get in
what visa was he on and how did he get a
weapon these are questions the uk and
u.s authorities are now urgently
examining and of course his motive too
the president joe biden is being kept
across the investigation as it develops
this was an act of terror this is an act
of terror i put a call into the rabbi we
miss one another on the way up here and
uh
but they should rest assured that we are
focused we are focused the attorney
general is focused on making sure that
we deal with these kinds of acts this
woman it seems could be key afiya sadiki
from pakistan originally now serving an
86-year prison term in texas for the
attempted murder of u.s soldiers
known as lady al-qaeda faysal akram had
demanded that she be released from
prison she's cited as a sort of very
famous al-qaeda female who's sitting in
american jail and has been there for a
very long time who people clamor for the
release of so you know it's not entirely
surprising that her case is the one
that's cited but i think it's certainly
curious that the case is the incident
has taken place so near to where she's
being incarcerated the hostages are free
the man who took them is dead but with
arrests in the uk and many questions
here this remains an open investigation
mark stone sky news in the united states